[Music]
my name is Richard Euler I'm a software
engineer on the Android runtime team I
spent the last three years trying to
better understand memories on Android
and more recently I've been working with
first party app developers to tackle the
challenges of evaluating and improving
Android memory use it's great to see so
many of you here interested in Android
memory use to start off why should you
as an app developer care about memory
use for me it's really about the Android
ecosystem the ecosystem of applications
of devices and of the users of those
devices and where memory comes in into
play is not so much for the premium
devices where you have a lot of memory
available but much more for the
entry-level devices because these
devices need a decent selection of
though memory apps to work well if
application memory use and requirements
grow then the entry-level devices won't
work as well if they don't work as well
om which will not want to produce these
devices and if they don't produce these
devices well we're kind of excluding a
bunch of users from arendt Android
ecosystem and that's a bad thing so app
developers have a role to play when they
were developing their applications to do
whatever they can to be efficient in
your memory use to reduce your memory
use keep it from growing too much so
that we have a nice selection of low
memory applications so that entry level
devices behave well they work well and
if that happens OMS will produce these
devices and we can put them in the hands
of users to use our applications so in
this talk I'm going to talk about three
broad categories three areas first I'll
talk about the mechanisms that come into
play on Android device when it's running
low on memory and how that impacts the
user I'll talk about how we evaluate an
applications memory in fact and in
particular some very important factors
to be aware of that
come into play with that and third I
will give you some tips for how to
reduce your applications memory in fact
especially given that a lot of the
allocations going on in your application
or originated deep within the Android
stack on which it's running okay
let's start what happens on the device
when it's running low on memory
well memory on device physical memory on
device is organized or grouped into
pages and each page is typically around
four kilobytes different pages can be
used for different things so pages can
be used pages these are pages that are
actively being used by processes they
can be cached pages these are pages that
of memory that are being used by
processes but the data they contain also
lives somewhere on the device storage
which means we can sometimes reclaim
these pages and then there might be free
pages of memory sitting on the device
that you're not using so what I've done
is I took a two gigabyte device and I
started it doing nothing so at the very
beginning of time the runtimes not
running and then I started using it more
and more so lots of different
applications exercising them which has
the effect of using more and more memory
on the device over time so we can see at
the beginning the flatline there is
before I started the runtime and I start
the runtime up there's plenty of free
memory available on the device and this
is a happy device because if an
application needs more memory the kernel
can satisfy that request right away from
the free memory over time as you use
more memory the free memory gets
exhausted it goes down and to avoid very
bad things from happening the Linux
kernel has this mechanism that kicks in
called K swap D and K swap T's job is to
find more free memory this kicks in when
the the free memory goes below what I'm
flying here the K swap D threshold and
the main mechanism that case WAP D uses
to find morph remember
is to reclaim cache pages now if an app
goes to access a cached page or memory
that was on a cached page that's been
reclaimed it's going to take a little
extra time to reload that data from
device storage but probably the users
not going to be noticing this so that's
that's okay
now as I exercise more and more
applications they use more memory the
number of cache pages is going to fall
as k swab D starts to reclaim them if it
gets too low there's too few cache pages
then the device can start to thrash and
this is a very bad thing because it's
basically the device will completely
lock up so on Android we have a
mechanism which is called the low memory
killer that kicks in when the amount of
cache memory falls too low and the way
this works is low memory killer is going
to kill pick the process on the device
and it's going to kill it and it's going
to get back all the memory that that
process was using now this is a this is
an unhappy state to be in especially if
the low memory killer kills a process
that the user cares about so let me go
through and tell you a little bit more
about how the low memory killer decides
what to kill Android keeps track of the
processes that are running on the device
and it keeps them in a priority order so
the highest priority processes are
native processes these are ones that
come with Linux things like init K swap
D which I told you about demons like net
D log D and Android specific daemons a
DB D install D basically any native
process that's running is categorized
into this the next highest priority
process we have is the system server
which is maintaining this list followed
by what are known as persistent
processes these are kind of core
functionality so telephony NFC SMS those
kinds of things next we have the
foreground app so this is going to be
the application that the user is
directly interacting with in this case
perhaps e users
a webpage so they're interacting with
the chrome app next in priority or what
are called perceptible or visible
processes these are not processes the
users directly interacting with but
perceptible in some way so for instance
if you have a search process maybe it
has a little bit of UI on the screen or
if the users listening to music in the
background then they can hear that music
to their headphones they can perceive it
after the perceptible apps we have
services these are services started by
applications for things like syncing or
uploading downloading from cloud and
then we have the whole map this is what
you get when you hit the home button
that often hosts your wallpaper if you
have something there so in addition to
these running processes we also keep
track of what the previous application
the user used was so maybe they're using
this red app that you're a red app and
it brings them to Chrome with a link
then when they've switched to Chrome
that app is going to be the previous app
and we also keep in memory a bunch of
other processes which are cached
applications the user used before some
of them may be recently some of them not
for a little bit of a while I want to
point out here that these cast processes
when I use the term cast this is a
different use of the term cast than the
cast memory pages I was talking about
previously okay so the reason we keep
around previous and cached processes is
because if a user wants to switch to one
of these applications and say they want
to switch to the previous application
it's very quick to switch to that oh I
should say this is for a device in a
normal memory state so if you want to
switch to a previous application that's
very quick but also if you want to
switch to an application that happens to
be in a cast process that's very quick
to do because it's already in memory if
we step back though and say well what
happens when the device is low on memory
in that case we could imagine the memory
used by the the running applications is
growing the
of cache pages drops below the low
memory killer threshold the low memory
killer now has to come in and kill
something to free up some memory what is
going to start killing from the bottom
to this list so maybe it kills this blue
application that's gone we get some more
memory back for the applications that
are still running but if the user now
wants to switch and start using that
blue application it's not cached any
longer it means it's going to take a
noticeably long time to launch that
application that could be 2 or 3 seconds
and maybe it's lost some state so this
is where the user first starts to really
feel Oh something something's going on
here that's making things slower if the
processes that are running continue to
use more memory so we get under more
memory pressure low memory killer is
going to start to kill more cache
processes if they continue to grow more
and more until eventually there's only a
few cast processes left at this point we
say the device memory status is critical
this is a very bad place to be if the
running processes continue to use more
memory though the low memory killer is
going to have to kill more processes
eventually it's going to end up killing
the whole map at this point the users
going to ask well hey what just happened
to my wallpaper because when they go
home it's gonna be a black screen for a
few seconds before the wallpaper starts
up again if it's even worse maybe a
perceptible process is killed the users
going to say hey what just happened to
my music I was listening and it just
stopped a really bad case the foreground
app is killed to the user this looks
like the app crashed and the most
extreme case you can get into for a low
memory killer basically it needs to kill
the system server this looks like your
phone is rebooted so these are all very
visible impacts of what happens when the
device is running low on memory and it's
not it's not a good user experience when
this is happening on your device ok I
want to go back to this graph that I was
showing before about what happens to the
memory pages on the device as
you use more memory this was a 2
gigabyte device what do you think it
looks like this graph for a 512 megabyte
device may give you a few seconds to
think about that
you have an idea what it looks like so I
tried it for a 512 megabyte device same
things start the run time use more
memory and it looks something like this
so because there's so little memory
available at the beginning there's very
few free pages that we can use up before
the case wop D has to kick in and then
there's very few cast pages we can
reclaim before the low memory color is
needed to start killing things and so
you can imagine if you have this device
and the low memory killer is always
active it's always going processes and
it leads to this bad user experience
[Music]
then maybe OEMs are not going to be too
interested in shipping this device
because well it just doesn't work well
and that gets back to the ecosystem
challenges I mentioned in the beginning
so this is why why we care about them
right now how do we figure out how much
memory and application is used how do we
know your applications memory in fact I
told you that memory on device is broken
down into pages the Linux kernel is
going to keep track for each process
running on a device which pages it's
using so maybe we have a system process
Google Play services process couple apps
running on a device we want to know each
of their memory impacts well just count
up the number of pages that is using
it's a little bit more complicated than
this
because of sharing because multiple
processes on the device can be sharing
memory so for instance if you have an
app that's calling into Google Play
services it's going to be sharing some
memory perhaps code memory or other
kinds of memory with the Google Play
services process and then we can ask how
should we account for this shared memory
is that part of the responsibility of
the application is that memory impact
something that we should care about and
there's a few different ways that you
can approach this one is to use what we
call a resident set size or RSS and what
this means is when we're counting in
apps RSS we're saying you
application is fully responsible for all
the pages of memory that it's sharing
with other applications another approach
is called proportional setsize PSS and
in this case we're going to say the app
is responsible for those shared pages
proportional to the number of processes
that are sharing them so in this case
two applications or processes sharing
these pages the application will we'll
say is responsible for half of them if
there were three processes sharing the
same memory we would say the application
is responsible for a third of them and
so on and then a third approach you can
take
it's called unique set size where we say
the application is not responsible for
any of its shared pages now in general
which approach to take really depends on
the context so for instance if those
shared pages we're not being used in the
Google Play Services app until your app
called in to Google Play services then
maybe it makes sense to say the app is
responsible for all of those pages we
want to use RSS on the other hand if
those pages were sitting in memory and
the Google Play services processed
before the app called in to Google Play
services they were always there the app
is not bringing them into memory then we
wouldn't want to count them USS would be
more appropriate in general we don't
have access to this high level context
to know at least at the system level so
the approach we take is the most
straightforward one which is
proportional set size with equal sharing
and one benefit of using PSS for
evaluating applications memory impact
especially when looking at multiple
processes at the same time is it will
avoid over counting or under counting of
shared pages okay
so use PSS for your applications memory
impact and you can run this command adb
shell dump system info dash s give it
your process name come that example dot
richard or whatever it is or you can
give the process ID if you happen to
know that and it's gonna output
something like this
and app summary view of the applications
memory and at the very bottom there's a
total and that number is the
applications PSS
this is adb shell dump system info - yes
okay
now let's say you do this you figure out
what the PSS of your application is
there's a very interesting question to
ask how much memory should your
application be using because you know I
say earlier if we use a lot of memory
that's bad with his low memory killer
kicks in but we're actually using memory
for a reason we're using it to provide
features to provide user value to
provide you know delightfulness
everything that makes our app great is
going to be taking up memory so we have
this trade-off between user value and
memory that's what I'm showing here in
this graph the trade-off space in an
ideal world we're kind of up into the
left on the graph where we're providing
a lot of user value without very much
memory impact at all but in practice
this is going to probably be technically
infeasible because you need memory to
provide value and there's only so much
value can provide with a limited amount
of memory on the other hand the other
extreme would be if you're using a lot
of memory to provide not much value and
I think it's safe to say this is not a
great app because it's basically it's
providing too much memory using too much
memory
unfortunately my slides are not showing
up right but there's imagine a curve on
which there's too much memory for this
app it's not worth it to the user to use
ah there they go
wonderful next we can look at this
corner of the graph where we're not
providing too much user value we're not
using too much memory we can say this is
like a small application maybe your desk
clock app and at the other end we can
have apps that use a lot of memory to
provide a lot of value these are large
applications maybe a photo editor
something like that and we can say well
what's better a small app or a large app
in this case there they can both be
useful except that when I've said that
an application is using too much memory
that really depends on what kind of
device you're running on if you're
running on a premium device it can
support much larger applications but on
a smaller device an entry-level device
maybe this large app uses too much
memory to make sense on that so really I
should be drawing a line and say too
much memory depends on the device
premium mid tier an entry level might
not support that large app for better or
for worse what I see happening often is
over time as you develop your
application you tend to add more
features it tends to take more memory so
you tend to go up and to the right in
this graph now this is actually good for
mid tier premium users because they're
getting more value more bang for their
buck memory wise but in this case it's a
little bit unfortunate for the entry
level device user because while he could
use the older version of your app you've
now added so many features and it's
using so much memory that it just
doesn't work as well on their device so
the points that I want to say here the
takeaways anything you can do to improve
your applications memory efficiency is
good so if you can move to the left on
this graph so less memory use without
sacrificing user value that's great and
just be aware that when you're adding
new features while it's good for it can
be good for materia Miam device users
there might be a negative consequence
for these entry level devices ok there's
something wrong with this graph does
anyone know what it is well let me say
the problem that this graph is it's
suggesting that an applications memory
use is one number so you give me this
application and I can tell you it's BSS
but in practice that's far from the case
because an applications memory impact
depends
on a whole bunch of different things
such as the application use case the
platform configuration and device memory
pressure and so this is important to be
aware of when you're testing your
applications memory perhaps testing for
regressions or to see if an optimization
is working to make sure that you're
testing the application use case you
care about and you're controlling all of
the other parameters so that you're
doing a proper apples to apples
comparison let me go into a little bit
more detail so how does an application
use case impact memory what I've done
here as I started using Gmail and I've
switched to different use cases in the
application of over time so every 20
seconds I switch I started by viewing
the Inbox it's using just a little over
a hundred megabytes PSS then I switch to
looking at an email that had some text
use it a little bit more memory I switch
to looking at a different email this one
time with pictures it uses more memory
then I started to compose an email use a
little bit less I stopped using the app
and then it used less memory so you can
see here that depending on the
application use case memory impact
varies quite significantly and it
doesn't necessarily make any sense to
compare your applications memory from
point A and point B because these are
different use cases okay
application use case is a pretty
straightforward factor something that's
less obvious is that your memory will
change a lot depending on what your
platform configuration is so what I
showing in this graph is I take one of
those application use cases from the
previous slide Gmail looking at an email
with pictures and I've run it on a bunch
of different devices so in X is 4 and X
is 5 X Nexus 6p pixel XL and also on a
number of different platform versions
even within the same device so for
instance for the Nexus 5 I ran it on
Android M and an O and you can see that
there's quite a variation
much memory this application use case is
taking up this comes about because well
for different devices we have different
screen resolutions different screen
sizes which means bitmaps take up
different amounts of memory you might
have different platform optimizations on
the different devices you might have a
different Saigo configuration different
runtime configuration its running your
code differently and so there's there's
a lot of different factors going on here
which mean when you switch to a
different platform configuration you're
going to get different memory use so I
would say when you're testing your
applications memory use try as hard as
you can to use a consistent platform set
up the same kind of device the same
platform version and the same scenario
of what's running on device and now
there's a third case I want to talk
about which is pretty interesting which
is a little bit counterintuitive which
is an applications memory impact depends
on the memory pressure on device so here
what I've done is I've taken Chrome
application and I started running it on
the device that had plenty of free
memory and then I set up some native
process in the background that's going
to slowly use it more and more memory on
the device so that I can see what
happens to Chrome when the device gets
under medium memory pressure or high
memory pressure and we can see when
there's plenty of free memory on the
device so low memory pressure Chrome's
PSS is pretty flat except for that
little spike which is probably some
variation in app use case for the
platform when the device gets under
enough memory pressure that case floppy
kicks in and starts to reclaim cache
pages while some of those pages that it
reclaims are going to be from the chrome
process and that's gonna cause phone's
memory impact to go down it's PSS is
going to go down until eventually if the
device has so much memory pressure the
low memory killer is active and it
decides it wants to kill chrome then VSS
for comb is going to very quickly drop
to zero
so what you can see here is that even
for the same application use case the
same platform configuration we have a
wide range of PSS values we might get
and so you have to be a little bit
careful imagine I've come up with this
optimized version of the Chrome apk and
it has this kind of lighter blue line
for the memory profile I'm confident
that this is an optimized version of the
APK from a memory standpoint because for
every level of device memory pressure it
uses less memory but if I'm doing a test
and I sample the PSS of the original
chrome version at point a but I sampled
the dss of the supposedly optimized
chrome version at point B and I compared
and they say oh well a is less than B so
a has less memory
I might falsely conclude that the
original burnt version of Chrome is
better than my optimized version so you
really have to be careful in comparing
VSS values to make sure that the device
memory pressure is the same otherwise
you can get these funny results my
advice because it's it's pretty hard to
control for device memory pressure is to
run your tests on the device that has
plenty of free RAM so that there's a low
device memory pressure and you can see
the PSS numbers will be much more stable
in that area okay so we talked about why
you want your applications not to take
up too much memory how you can evaluate
your applications memory impact let me
now give you some tips for how to reduce
your applications memory impact and the
first tip is check out Android Studios
memory profiler profile your
applications Java heap this is going to
give you a ton of information useful
information about the Java objects on
your heap so where they're allocated
what's holding on to them how big they
are and pretty much anything you want to
know about the Java heap you can see
from this my tip for you is to focus on
the app heap so if you open this up in
Android studio you'll see three heaps
there's a zygote heap on the image heap
when the app keep the image heap and the
zygote heap are inherited from the the
system when your application first
launches so there's not much you can do
about that but definitely you can do a
lot on the App Keith I'm not gonna go
into a ton of detail on how you would
use this tool or actually not very much
at all because Esteban is going to be
giving a talk tomorrow 12:30 on exactly
how to use this tool his team built the
tool he's going to be talking about how
to do live allocation tracking and deep
analysis so I highly recommend you go
check out that talk tomorrow at 12:30 ok
so you say Richard you've told us that
we should care about TSS that's our
applications memory in fact you just
told us we should use the Android
Studios memory profile to profile the
Java heap but if we look here we see
well the gentleman keeps not actually
all that much of the overall memory
impact of the application what about all
the rest of this memory what should we
do here this is tricky because most of
these applications or our allocation
sorry are originating deep within the
platform stack the Android stack so if
you want to know about them and really
understand them it helps to know a lot
more about say how frameworks is
implementing the view system or
resources or power the native libraries
fonts and sequel light and resources ah
sorry webview is working from the
Android runtime how it's running your
code from the hardware abstraction layer
how graphics is working all the way down
to virtual memory management management
in the Linux kernel by the way I live in
the orange block in the middle of the
Android runtime that's where I am in
this step so you might ask ok so these
this memory is coming from the platform
or within the platform should we be
using platform tools to diagnose this
memory
for instance if dumpsters mem info - s
that summary view isn't enough you could
try running dump system info with - a to
show basically everything you can see
from a platform perspective about your
applications memory use this will give
you a much more detailed breakdown for
instance instead of seeing your your
code memory regressed you can see is it
because my dot s o memory mappings have
regressed or my dot apk or Dex M memory
mappings have regressed it'll also show
you a breakdown of the different
categories of memory so private clean
shared dirty and so on private dirty
memory is like the used memory I was
talking about at the beginning
private clean memory the clean suggests
it's it's like the cache memory that
also lives on this so you could use dump
system info if that's not enough detail
maybe you see ok dot a PKM that
progressed there's this tool called show
map you can do run on your application
and it's going to give you an even more
fine-grained breakdown of your memory
memory memory mappings and it'll
actually give you specific files that
are being memory mapped in your
application and this can help pinpoint
what files might might have led to
regressions in the platform we have a
heap dump viewer that I've developed
experimental heap dump you were called a
hat that tries to surface more platform
specific things you could try using that
to learn more about your Java heap
though Android Studios memory profile
will have all the same information and
then we also have on the platform
something called debug malloc this is
where you can instrument your
application so that every native
allocation it makes it's going to save a
back-trace a stack trace to that
allocation you take a what we call a
native heap snapshot of your app when
it's running instrumented and if you
have the symbols you can D symbolize the
stack traces and you can get native
stack traces for all of your native
allocations
this has quite a bit of overhead at
runtime and so it can be a little bit
tricky to work but it provides a lot of
insight into the native feed so we have
these platform tools should we use them
can we use them well certainly you could
they're all available but some caveats
with these tools they tend not to be
well supported
they have very clumsy user interfaces as
you you just witnessed from my snapshots
this approach requires quite a bit of
deep platform expertise to understand
for instance oh it's the difference
between decks and matvey decks and map
out and map where are these things
coming from for instance you might need
to have a rooted device such as in the
case for show map and debug malloc you
might have to build a platform yourself
if you want to get your hands on a hat
or the symbols that debug mouth needs to
symbolise the numbers tend to be pretty
noisy because you're looking at memory
at a page level and a lot of the memory
use you'll see from these tools is kind
of outside of your control anyway so you
might see zygote allocations runtime
allocations that that aren't related to
your code so I don't think that this is
the best use of your time to try and use
these tools though by all means go ahead
and try them out I'm gonna give a bit of
a different suggestion which is if you
want to improve your overall memory use
do two things 1 profile your Java heap
using Android studio as memory profiler
like I showed before and to reduce your
apk size and let me tell you why I think
this is a reasonable approach for you to
take to reduce your overall memory
impact first is that allocations that
are outside of the Java heap many of
those are tied to Java allocations so
your application is coined into the
Android frameworks which is coin into
native libraries under the cover which
is doing native allocations or even
graphics allocations whose lifetime is
tied to Java objects for instance just
to give you a sampling
in Java on your Java heap if you see
these kinds of objects so a sequel like
database web views patterns those are
all have native out allocations
associated with them if you see a Dex
file object that's gonna have Dex and
nap D Dex coat and map associated with
it if you have thread instances on your
Java heap that's gonna be associated
with stack memory and if you're using
bitmaps or sometimes surface views or
text reviews that can lead to graphics
memory use and there are many others so
if you want if you're focusing on your
Java heap you're worried is not gonna
help anywhere else that's not true
optimizations on your Java heap are
going to help with other memory
categories as well
I am trying as part of my job to surface
better this information about these kind
of non Java heap allocations and you
start to see that if you look at Android
Studios memory profilers it'll report a
number called native and I just wanted
to let you know this is this is kind of
an approximation or a suggestion of some
of the non Java memory that might be
associated with a Java object take it
with a little bit of a grain of salt but
it works really well for surfacing the
memory impact so say bitmaps okay my
second suggestion was reduce your apk
size and why do you do this because a
lot of things that take up space in your
apk take up space in memory at runtime
as well for instance your class's Dex
file is going to take up space on the
Java heap in terms of class objects it's
going to take a code memory for the
memory map Dex file it's also going to
take up what shows up in private other
in the app summary view runtime metadata
representations for your fields methods
and strings and so on if you have
bitmaps in your apk when those are
loaded at runtime the pixel data is
going to take up space depending on the
platform version or how you've loaded
them either in the Java heat the native
heap or as graphics resources in your
apk take up space on the Java heat
say you have an asset manager object
also on the native heap you have a
parsed zip file structure that shows up
there and you're gonna have code memory
for your a PKM map and dot iso files if
you have if you're shipping libraries
J&I native libraries with your
application when you're accessing those
libraries at runtime it's going to take
up space so all of these things if you
can shrink them you reduce your apk size
you reduce your memory size and I will
tell you that measuring apk size
reliably is much easier than memory
because for an apk you actually do have
one number for the size if you measure
the apk size for a single apk repeatedly
you will get the same result very much
unlike memory there was a top at Google
i/o last year called best practices to
slim down your app size I recommend you
check that out that will give you more
advice more concrete action items you
can take to to shrink these things ok
let me do a quick recap why we care
about memory what I suggest you do to
improve your applications memories so
first I talked about how as we use more
memory on device the low memory killer
is going to eventually kick in is going
to kill processes if the user cares
about these processes that's bad if the
device is getting low memory killers
running too much then homes won't want
to produce the low-end sorry entry level
device then we lose those devices we
lose those users to evaluate your
applications memory impact use PSS
anything you can do to improve your
memory efficiency is good when you're
testing for memory regressions or
optimizations make sure you're targeting
the application use case you care about
and controlling for the platform
configuration test on the device that
has plenty of free RAM to help control
for device memory pressure and to reduce
your applications memory use do try out
Android Studios memory
filer focus on the app beep go to the
session that Esteban's giving tomorrow
12:30 to learn more about how to do that
do what you can to reduce your apk size
and check out the talk from last year on
how you can do that so thank you all for
coming
I would love to chat with you more and
hear more about the memory challenges
you're facing so you'll find me I'll
hang out for a little while out outside
after the stage and you can also find me
at the Android runtime office hours
which are 5:30 so that's just a couple
hours in 10th F after this talk thank
you very much
[Music]
you